mafia 3 might be the most ambitious
title in the series yet set in 1968 in a
fictional New Orleans mafia 3 tells the
story of Lincoln clay a biracial Vietnam
veteran who returns from the war to bind
his home in shambles the black mob the
only thing he has ever called family has
been torn down and the Italian mob has
set up shop with the help of the Irish
mob a self-exiled Italian mobster from
up north and the well-connected leader
of the Haitian gang Lincoln will tear
down the organization from within and
perhaps find a place to be long
recently I got hands-on time for almost
three hours of Mafia 3 and here's what I
saw that I liked this is the first truly
open world Mafia game and it allows you
to tackle each mission in many different
ways similar to how you could and rise
at the Tomb Raider and shadow of Mordor
these missions all take place in the
city of hue or doe which is broken up
into nine districts each district also
has its own crime racket going on
extortion seizing and reselling of
gasoline and construction materials drug
and prostitution rings moonshine brewing
it is all there to get the job done you
can do a number of things from sneaking
into back entrances to running in guns
blazing depending on what path you take
he'll also see different story content
for example when infiltrating the hotel
where a particularly despicable mobster
lives I had two choices I could go to
the garage steal a car and engage in
some subterfuge and sneak up through the
hotel from the basement or I could have
walked into the lobby and just started
shooting each choice offers different
scenarios and in some cases how you
choose to enter a mission can mean life
or death for other characters time and
place matter to see some parts of the
story and by the way I win in guns
blazing
another cool thing you can do is wiretap
areas to reveal the location and type of
enemy's wiretapping essentially unlocks
Lincoln's Intel vision which shows you
where your target is in which enemy is
going to try and call for reinforcements
if they see you through gifting your
three subordinates
that's feet over Cassandra with the
districts and safe houses you conquer
you can unlock new tools for dealing
with these situations veto gives you
better guns and inventory earth will
provide you with Irish mob members for
you to call into fights and Cassandra
will give you the ability to cut the
phone lines in specific areas so enemies
can't call reinforcements there's a ton
of tools at your disposal and they don't
just link to combat as you unlock access
to more vehicles yes those amazing
1960's muscle cars Lincoln can have them
delivered to him wherever he is in the
city these cars handle like boats too
similar to how to handle in real life
and if you can't be bothered to call a
car you can always steal one but you
can't keep it and I can't talk about
mafia 3 without mentioning the
soundtrack developer hangar 13 is packed
the game with licensed tracks from
artists at the time like Creedence
Clearwater Revival Aretha Franklin
Lonnie Youngblood Sam Cooke and more as
I got into my car once the Rolling
Stones paint black came on the radio
it's an amazing experience to ride
around with these songs on the radio or
to walk into a bar and hear them playing
it really grounds the game in real life
I had a lot of fun during my time with
Ma Pa
it feels like it was built on the backs
of games like Tomb Raider and shadow of
Mordor her players unlock skills and
resources at their discretion and have a
delicate balancing act in deciding what
to prioritize and what to forego you can
even choose to kill or spare the enemies
you interrogate building up your empire
or taking no prisoners there's a lot to
do and a lot to keep track of which is
perfect for the open-world setting in
the brief time I had I really felt like
I was making my mark on fictional New
Orleans this time around mafias story is
really up to you